hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs will solve all the
major problems of the world so to help
you on your journey I'm going to share
today the seven ways that smart people
they call and as always guys as you
listening if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in comments below
I put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and the more you write
it down for yourself
the more likely it's going to stick in
here as well enjoy we number one is have
a schedule one of the things that really
helped me stay calm with all those
things that were happening in my
business was to have a schedule and I
know that there's a time for the thing
that is causing an issue and so for
example Tuesday is my youtube days when
I review all the videos from my team
it's when I answer any questions when I
do setups for collaborations when I'm
doing the research anything basically
YouTube related except for filming I do
on a Tuesday and so whenever I get
emails during the week I get questions I
get proposals I get ideas I review a
video that then spawns another creation
I have a place I put it in my folder and
I know on Tuesday I'm going to have time
to go out and do it and I think often
times when we don't have time to figure
it out we try to rush to solve it it
creates chaos
it creates stress but knowing that you
have a place in your calendar to be able
to do it for me at least creates a great
sense of table number two is create a no
crisis business this is a huge thing I'm
a fan of as an entrepreneur I hate
having to deal with crisises crisises
crises I hate having to deal with crises
in the moment I hate having a crisis
business and so it's a reason why I
don't use a phone because what happens
when you have a phone people call you
people call you with what they think is
an emergency but it's really their use
for your time right it's their agenda
for your time instead of you saying I'm
protecting my time and focus on the
things that really matter to me and so
sometimes this means you have to fire
clients you know if I look at my main
business most brands who approached me
with a deal I
don't work with some of them just have
the wrong intentions but some of them
are just too needy if you need me to be
on call 24/7 for your project to be a
success we're not going to work well
together that deal is not going to
happen because I want to create a new
crisis business and so sometimes that
means you lose opportunities right
sometimes that means that I will miss
media opportunities as an example
because the reporters on a tight
deadline it needs an answer by four
o'clock today and I've even get the
email until two o'clock the next day
sometimes that happens but you have to
be willing to let go of the good to go
for the great I'm using that time with
intention to focus on big most important
projects for my company as opposed to
only dealing with little fire if the
little fire at the little fire as much
as possible create a no crisis business
[Music]
number three is close your eyes and
breathe this sounds like a pretty basic
one but just just reminding yourself
that this is stressful I'm going to
breathe I'm going to close my eyes I'm
going to relax as things start to get
better why do people go outside first
smoke
like the nicotine health but it's also
the breathing and so if there's a
reminder on your calendar or something
on your desktop background or whenever
you feel that stress coming onboard just
reminding yourself I'm going to close my
eyes I'm going to take a couple deep
breaths I instantly feel a little bit
more calm so rule number four is to have
perspective I think a lot of the times
we get really focused on the Nitty
Gritty of things of like things that are
happening you have like emails coming
through you have telephone calls coming
through and we lose perspective and
what's important so just last night I
was ready to teach my Zumba class you
know I had my laptop ready everything
was ready to go I have my playlist
everything is going as planned ten
minutes before my class starts my laptop
shuts down
it just shuts down completely and I
started to panic and I couldn't turn it
back on and immediately my thought was
oh my god this happens to me all the
time why does technology hate me so much
like this has happened before many times
and then I started replaying all these
weird things happening like what if the
girls come in and I don't have the right
playlist and then what do I do
what if I forget everything what if I
have no music oh god do I go on youtube
to download music what is it and I just
start spiring spiraling out of control
and I felt a physiological change in my
body I started turning really red and I
felt like sickness come over my stomach
I'm like oh gosh this is anxiety it's
happening again I'm getting anxious and
at that point I took five minutes psych
okay I'm gonna give myself five minutes
I'm going to go in the back room and put
things in perspective it's a laptop it's
fine it shut down it's okay I have
another playlist on my phone
yes it's an old playlist and I haven't
done it since a year ago but I still
have a playlist it's going to be fine
you know what's important is that I have
a group of students coming in with giant
smiles on their faces wanting to do
Zumba want to get a nice workout and
want an environment that is supportive
and encouraging and I want them to feel
like they could love all of themselves
and me concerned about a laptop or how
technology's always after me and nothing
could ever get done because technology
hates me it's not going to help my
situation so that's five minutes I calm
down I put things in perspective and
five minutes later I found my old
playlist I played it it wasn't ideal but
it was still an amazing class and
everyone left really really happy so
next time you feel like things are
spiraling out of control and you can't
keep focus and things are going wrong
just remember to put everything
and perspective number five has changed
your environment so sometimes just
getting up and going for a walk really
helps I would find myself sometimes
getting stressed out at my old office
and a session a nice day I would spend
fifteen minutes and just go for a quick
walk clear my head I really actually
found it helpful between switching tasks
so if I if I had to go from writing
something really intense that I had a 90
minute chunk to work on and then I had
to switch to some other task I would use
that 15 minutes to clear my head to just
change my environment and to set myself
up to have success for that next chunk
of time I find that sometimes it's the
people right in front of you or that
environment that triggers you and just
going for a walk and changing it can
help bring you a sense of calm number 6
is remember your why another thing I
find really helpful is remembering what
I'm doing why is it so important Who am
I trying to help what's my mission and
so if you're dealing with some little
stress that might be overwhelming in the
moment thinking about I'm doing this
thing because I want to help
entrepreneurs because my work matters
because people leave comments and all
these videos and say how important a lot
of videos are to them to stay motivated
to given them idea to tea to build
amazing things and so the stress of one
hater or a video not you know being
ready on time or having to switch around
the schedule those kind of things that
can happen are small in comparison to
the why of what I'm trying to accomplish
and keeping that focus and whenever I'm
kind of stressed out remembering back to
why am I doing this why is it so
important to me helps put those other
things not seem so big and number seven
is meditate and I put this as number
seven because I don't really meditate
I've never found a way to really make it
work for me but it works for other
people so I had to include it on the
list for whatever reason I've really
wanted to learn to meditate I've been on
and off with meditation for I don't know
at least a decade I just don't feel the
benefit of it I really want to though
remember we went to this Tony Robbins
event a month or two ago in Caliph
and they had this meditation guy come on
and we're supposed to meditate we're
supposed to like feel this ball of
energy between us and like how many you
can feel the ball and like I don't feel
the ball I don't I don't know if I
wanted where's the ball or the bar I can
feel the ball I'm getting stressed out
trying to feel the ball and then and
then the next exercise you have to stand
up and put your hand over somebody's
head and like feel the energy field over
the head and like I can't feel the
energy field how many you guys feel the
energy field everybody shoots up their
hand like I can't feel their energy
field so you know I don't know why I
think it may be in general I'm just
pretty calm I don't get stressed out
that easily but I'm going to add it on
the list and hopefully maybe you guys
will give me a resource that I can use
that finally the resource that will
click with me so that meditation can be
an important part of our daily routine
so that's my take on the seven ways that
smart people stay calm I'd love to know
what did you guys think which way was
most relevant impactful valuable to you
leave it down in the comments below also
is there an 8 9 10 that I missed that
you want to add to the list that really
helps you please share it because think
it'll help a lot of entrepreneurs who
are watching this video as well so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon